welcome back 8 news now narska and NV
Energy is helping you stay cool this
summer we're gifting you a cool day
installing four HVAC units to four lucky
residents if you're a homeowner with an
HVAC unit 20 years or older or you don't
have a working HVAC unit at all go to
8newsnow.com and click on gifting you a
cool day to enter now the summer heat is
fast approaching which makes now the
perfect time to get an AC tune-up power
shift by NV Energy the sponsors of this
next segment is offering low cost and no
cost AC tune-ups for customers take a
look
one of the worst things living in Las
Vegas is it's summertime you come home
from work open the front door and the
house is warm your AC is out now instead
of worrying about that day happening you
can prevent it but Jeremy first things
first why isn't AC tune-up so important
you know when it's hot in Las Vegas you
want to make sure your air conditioner
is working not only that it's working
but it's working efficiently we all know
that on those hot summer days air
conditioner bills can get higher and
when a unit's running as it's supposed
to be as designed by the manufacturer
it'll help keep your bills lower now
when you and your crew come out and
start doing a service on an AC what are
you looking for when it comes to
maintenance what do you walk me through
the process here sure so what Jeffrey's
doing here is he's actually checking the
refrigerant charge right now he wants to
make sure that one the refrigerant
charge is right he's also going to be
inspecting the coil to make sure that
it's free and Clean from any debris he's
going to be checking all of the moving
Parts your Motors he's going to be
checking your capacitors to make sure
that they are operating and that the
compressors draws on power are where
they're supposed to be so that it's not
only guaranteed to keep working but it's
running as optimally and efficiently as
possible when you're looking at an AC
unit just for the visual eye can you see
anything wrong with it well you have to
Deep dive into this thing to find the
issues you know most of the time we have
to Deep dive that's why Jeffrey's got
his iPad here he's got his gauges here
and he's checking things so that he
knows what it's really doing now
you might call it a fear or just a
concern is that you're going to come out
here and you're going to find something
that needs to be repaired is that what
you're looking for you just want us to
have the the best working AC possible
you know we want you to have the best
working AC possible we want to make sure
that you don't have to call us in the
summertime because when it's 110 degrees
and it's Fourth of July you don't want
to see us I'd rather be out at your
house when it's nice outside making sure
that it's continuing to run and that's
continuing to run very efficiently now
when it comes to a tune-up how often
should you should you have it done once
a year every two years every once a year
it should be done once a year absolutely
people watching have never had an ac
tune up raise your hand
I need you to come out to my house done
and you guys also work very closely with
Envy energy within sentence we do
absolutely they're a strategic partner
they have got some amazing incentives
right now to make sure that your system
is operating as a design well this is
Patricia with NV Energy so what are some
of the incentives that you guys offer so
one of the incentives that we do offer
is uh it's a 50 for all customers to get
a tune-up and it's 100 free for income
qualified customers to to get AC
tune-ups these are great savings right
there why is it so important for you to
have us the customers get our ACS tuned
up so it's very important during hot
summer months to make sure that you save
energy that you conserve and that your
AC unit is working on Tip-Top shape so
we want our customers to be comfortable
and to also be able to save money during
the hot summer months and not it can't
be anyone that comes out here you guys
have a list approved vendors that can
come do the service how do we get more
information yes you go to our website
and there we have the list of all the
qualified vendors that we worked
together with our AC program in our tuna
Ram
thank you to NV Energy for sponsoring
this segment visit their website
nvenergy.com
powershift low-cost tune-ups 250 income
qualified cost tune-ups that's zero
dollars for them that's I mean great
specials they have going on yeah 50 just
to get a tune-up that's amazing